sitting here with you too
bono ed
larry adam
you know this is uh such a throw for us
we're a real thrill they're giving me a
moses voice effect here um i am god uh
we knew that we knew that thank you uh
i hope people take that out of context
uh
uh first of all i wanna say this is
fascinating to me uh this is uh this is
the same studio where you guys made your
first united states television
appearance on the tom snyder show i
don't know exactly what year that was
but what year was it like 81 uh you're
back in the same space
uh it's great good to see they've
changed the carpet yeah they changed the
carpet yeah now you can get out of the
business yeah uh
i i'm curious i have a lot of questions
um first of all i don't know who to
direct this to but i'll just start with
you adam uh is it true that in the
beginning
when the group first began
bono was going to be the lead guitarist
or wanted to be the lead guitarist is
that true he definitely wanted to be the
lead guitarist and what happened
well then he became the rhythm guitarist
and then he became the manager
and then he elected to become the singer
right it worked out pretty good in the
end right right where did you get the
feeling that they were trying to edge
you out somehow no pun intended but were
they trying to were they trying to move
you along
yeah well you know i just i was stuck
for a job and uh i would have taken you
know anything i was ready to uh be then
the road crew and uh you know but i
don't i don't deal with the gear very
well right right you thought i'll be the
singer i'll give it a shot
uh you've gone through so many
transformations you've managed to stay
vital in this business for so long it's
funny to look back now we actually have
a photo that dates the band a little bit
can we see this photo here obano this is
you back in the day
you want to you want to explain what was
going on there well a man should never
look like his hair's been ironed um
first of all i'm not the one to give
advice but uh
it's just
yeah no something was exploding there
wasn't it yeah yeah underneath all of
that there was something
it's a nice look
you know you've gone through you the
whole band has gone through so many uh
changes you had that uh period where you
guys looked sort of like flock of
seagulls i don't know if people remember
this but take a look right here
then there was that time that the edge
left and joined kid and play i don't
know if you remember that ladies and
gentlemen
very shocking
and then no one likes to remember your
heavy period you guys were fat for a
while there it wasn't pleasant
you've done such a
well you're not coming back
you're the the the stage show you've
brought so much vitality to your stage
performances and you guys have been so
great at using the visual medium uh was
there any idea that you tried a costume
a prop and later on you thought maybe
not the best idea
uh well there's a few but i suppose
dressing up as a 40-foot mirrorball
lemon spaceship um was probably a lemon
spaceship yes yeah meatball
believe it or not it was it was a sword
we had in the back of our head sort of
parliament funkadelic george clinton
sure sure for white boys that was pretty
brave right right
and there was an idea that i guess that
you've you've thought about doing but
you've never quite had the guts that
involves a
dead cowboy am i right about this
ooh
uh
these things shouldn't be talked about
at all
that's what this show is for basically
that's what we do here yes secrets yeah
yeah um okay secret
it there was an idea to uh we thought it
was very avant-garde to um to fly me in
a cowboy hat over the audience as a dead
cowboy
we thought it would be a one-off event
and it would be you know historically
remembered the face larry just made lara
is just like oh my god i remember that
it was explained then by our management
that john bon jovi did this every night
nothing's original
now larry this band you you this you
really got this band together it was you
who started everything really you put
out an ad in the local in your high
school is that right that's right i'm
guilty you're the one that's guilty and
the band rehearsed at your home is that
true in your kitchen my kitchen 29 years
this week
really
so larry
you
you made it all happen why isn't the
band called uh the larry mohan quartet
what
have you ever pushed for that i mean
it's not too late to be honest it was
going to be that for about the first 20
minutes of the first meeting it kind of
makes sense that that you know i think
that he had it on his base
the larry mullen band was there i
thought max was a very big
influence yeah
it all starts when you put it on the
bass drum yeah
well
i i thought it would be a really good
idea you know to follow in the tradition
yeah the drummer be the leader sure as
adam pointed out it's kind of difficult
to lead from behind
that's why max had himself raised up and
shoved forward
i might i might just mention the last
time a a a a great rock and roll band
had a very good looking drummer he was
called pete best and where is he now oh
that's true that's a good point he just
had a documentary actually on the bbc
he's flying high oh sorry okay uh
beatles who remembers them uh
i want to ask you something i've been
curious about i've encountered this you
know being an irish person i've
encountered a little bit myself which
there's an irish mentality which is good
for you
but don't get a big head
meaning they
they're happy for you but it's a very
tricky culture where they they kind of
they don't want you to get too big and i
think this must be a problem for you
guys because you're some of the biggest
stars in the world
but you go home to your country do you
encounter that feeling ever
you know it's it's a it's it's an
amazing place to escape
to
and ireland is really it's a really cool
place to live and to bring up your kids
and all of that kind of thing but one of
the reasons is because irish people are
so messy
and um it's very different than in
america in america you know you look up
the mansion on the hill and you say you
know one day
i'm going to live in that mansion in in
dublin where we come from especially on
the north side people look at the match
in the hill and go one day i'm going to
get that son of a [ __ ]
a different thing
yeah i'm familiar with that yeah you'd
have a problem in dublin just the tall
puppy syndrome what's that oh what's the
tall puppy syndrome just i mean just
because i'm tall and and look like a
goofball what do you mean
just uh uh no nothing
well now you're not coming back
[Music]
uh this is a uh we still have uh a lot
more to come uh as if i have to mention
it's doing so well but you two's how to
dismantle an atomic bomb is in stores as
if you don't already have it but get it
again why not
and uh you're coming back uh you're
gonna perform again we still have a lot
more show to go thank you so much for
being here stay tuned everybody